and the uh details keep trickling in for
Doctor Who this time we have another
casting announcement Jonathan Groff is
going to be playing a key guest role now
uh like a lot of the announcements I
don't have all that much to say about
this until we know more about who it is
he's actually playing you could make
some assumptions if you wanted to
because he does in theory kind of fit
the theatrical nature of a lot of the
guest casts that have been announcing
you know Patrick Harris Jinx Monsoon Etc
and while he is best known for more
theatrical roles like the king in
Hamilton or uh Kristoff in Frozen but
the thing is guys actually got more
range than he's usually given credit for
I know we've all kind of collectively
decided we're going to pretend the
fourth Matrix movie didn't happen even
though it was pretty good actually but
his take on Smith was pretty good and
interesting and compelling and so until
we know more about the character I'm not
going to make any assumptions because
he's got more range than he's given
credit for so we'll see